hugh james
michener prenez-vous janelle neutz pour être votre
épouse légalement mariée et ce que vous faites de
votre plein gré et de votre choix
je ne
vois pas le regard de shanghai vers le bas en
revenant à ce qu'il était
vous savez six  il y a des mois euh n'importe
quand n'importe quand bientôt
donc c'était un peu mordre la balle en tirer le
meilleur parti et malheureusement bien
heureusement ça a fait boule de neige c'était
vraiment juste nous dans notre salon le
faisant comme si nous étions de temps en temps
la prochaine chose  nous avons vous savez qu'une
robe de mariée est arrivée de nos amis un
gâteau de mariage un bouquet de fleurs
[Musique]
nous avons pu descendre et la
récupérer après qu'elle ait été désinfectée à la
porte d'entrée donc vous savez si ce n'était pas pour
ça et  si ce n'était pas pour les faits que
nos composés euh nous avions été autorisés à
descendre dans le parking
avec des masques et cetera euh tu sais que ce
mariage aurait pu être
une chose différente
ouais littéralement marié depuis notre
chaise longue euh donc au moins nous  ont pu obtenir
le euh le c  pièce d'elebration en bas
et vous savez que l'enceinte a été plutôt
agréable à ce sujet
[Musique]
je pense que tout le monde cherche juste de l'espoir en
ce moment vous savez qu'il n'y a pas de verrouillage,
pas de fin de verrouillage en vue et vous connaissez
toute nouvelle positive que vous connaissez en vous
mariant dans l'enceinte  euh, vous savez en
ligne via zoom dans les États-Unis, vous savez avec une
famille connectée du monde entier,
c'est probablement le maximum que vous puissiez tirer
de la situation en ce moment, je sais que vous
étiez un peu euh
un peu
pas très bien à ce sujet
chose de mariage mais ouais
nous c'était au-delà de nos attentes, nous ne nous attendions pas
vraiment à ce que ce soit si
romantique